uh
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
be seated we're ready to proceed thank
you all for being here on time we did
clear up a few minor legal matters so
we're ready to proceed with the
continued cross-examination of dr hassan
officer can you bring dr hassan in
please thank you
hi doctor welcome back
i'm going to ask you to remain standing
because we had a break we're going to
re-swear you you've been through this
before i can see that raise your right
hand please listen do you so in the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony gives to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth do
please state your nameless by your last
name for the record my name is charles s
hassan
h.a.s.s.o.n thank you all right doctor
be seated
mr shellhorn
you may continue your cross-examination
thank you judge
good afternoon doctor good afternoon
i think uh where we left off yesterday
was asking you some questions about the
dsm
uh would you agree with me that there's
no diagnosis in the dsm that's
dispositive of any legal standard
i don't know about that
i doubt it
because um
psychiatric
diagnoses and legal standard are two
separate domains
so they may not uh overlap
so meaning that if you find or diagnose
someone with a specific diagnosis that
doesn't automatically mean they
immediately well first of all i spelled
out in my report in a lot of detail
that when you're doing a report you have
to determine the purported
forensic report the purported intent of
the action then what you have to do is
to link the important and the purported
intent with the diagnosis those two then
the third step is to take those two
factors the diagnosis report ported
intent and then related to
either diminish capacity or a criminal
uh responsibility so if you skip
the steps rather than getting you know
do step one or step two you have to do
all three so it's uh
to answer you directly
unless you spell it out there's no
set
standard for a relationship between
diagnosis and the legal standard
meaning that just because you diagnose
someone with delusional disorder it
doesn't automatically mean they need a
legal standard i think on page 25 of
your book they point out the fact that
these are the steps you have to do you
have to relate the diagnosis to some
kind of functional deficit relate the
functional deficit to the diagnosis
so i think you're saying that you agree
with me i don't know what you i'm sorry
to say this way but i'm not sure i fully
understand what you're you're you're
thinking if you if you die and maybe
just try answering my question
diagnosis does not necessarily mean that
it meets a particular standard you have
to demonstrate
according to dsm 5
the steps along the way how you went
from
the
purported intent
the diagnosis those two factors and then
related to the legal statute
so if someone is diagnosed with
delusional disorder it doesn't
automatically mean that they meet a
legal standard
correct you have to demonstrate the
connection that's stated clearly in the
dsm-5
now you uh were aware of dr simran's
diagnosis before you rendered your
opinion
uh yes
and you agreed with him that this
defendant suffers from delusional
disorder persecutory type yes
you would agree that a person with
delusions is capable of knowing right
versus wrong it depends on the situation
because
paranoid delusions
is a dimension and i said the other day
it goes from normal population into
very disturbed people so it depends on
what part of that normal curve you're
talking about
you'd agree with me that a person with
delusions
could understand the nature and quality
of their actions you totally have to
spell that out a lot more it depends on
the circumstance there's not like a
black or white type of delusional
disorder
there's dimensionality here
doctor how do you define a delusion
i i mentioned the other day it's a
a belief
based on incorrect thinking
basically there's an experience then
there's a belief
based on incorrect thinking that comes
to a conclusion
that the person is not going to change
no matter what kind of argument you give
so it's a thought that was produced
uh
incorrectly i gave examples
when i interviewed
mr barristone of the uh odd thinking
that he had and i thought it was an
unusual you know finding but then i say
that um
some other people completely independent
of me but on a much higher level
have observed the same thing with
regards to delusions that it's a
cognitive processing difficulty someone
from
university of hawaii has written
extensively on that but i didn't know
that before i observed those behaviors
in him
so would you agree with me that a
delusion is a false belief it's a false
belief yes
what is michael barisson's specific
delusion
um well i touched on it yesterday and
instead of fireworks
he felt he believes that if he was he or
mary haskins was
incarcerated for some purported dsm
excuse me some purported deifis
violation
that the children were going to be
hunted down and killed he felt that very
strongly
i don't believe that but you know
so his specific delusion
i'm sorry to
thank you
so his specific delusion
in your opinion
is related to an
incarceration arising from the dc it's
so much broader than that
his delusion is this incredible fear
he's frightened that he'll be
his life mary haskins life the
children's life will be snuffed out
that's why he sent the boy to north
carolina he was frightened he got very
upset
when he saw that
a robert
goodman good good
win
was searching the internet for
information regarding the children he
took that information
and misconstrued doctor doctor good
night
ladies and gentlemen once again i need
to strike that answer
it's an improper answer i struck it
yesterday
i'm striking it again today
and hopefully we won't hear it again
you understand that doctor correct
there's no evidence supporting that
well please disregard it don't consider
it in your deliberations
ask your next question
doctor if you don't understand my
question please just ask me to rephrase
it and i'll do the best that i can
and even if you understand the question
just answer his question to the best of
your ability if mr blinkist needs to
follow up with you he'll follow up we
call that redirect
answer the prosecutor's question
so my question is not about the basis
for your opinion
my question was what is the specific
delusion that you have diagnosed for
michael barrasso if phil says life has
threatened
by lauren kanarak
and robert goodwin
when did that delusion that specific
delusion start well it started over a
period of time i would say well over a
month
it gradually increased
in intensity but it wasn't just like two
days as well over several weeks
or many weeks
what specific piece of evidence do you
rely on
that the delusion began well over a
month before the shooting well no one
can tell exactly when the delusion
began
but
based on um his
responding to information he was told he
read and things that occurred it made
him more more frightened
you didn't identify in your report
a specific piece of evidence that shows
that the delusion began well over a
month before the shooting
i didn't no i did not
and you'd agree with me that among the
diagnostic
criteria
for delusional disorder is that the
delusion existed for at least one month
yes i understand that
now you found that the defendant suffers
from a subtype of delusional disorder
persecutory type yes
what are the symptoms or characteristics
of persecutory type
delusional disorder well
as it says
he feels as if he feels as if there's a
danger out there he feels threatened
personally he feels that uh all the
things he's doing are being monitored
and he feels as if
that someone
can plan to kill him
and i'm not talking about michael
barrasson in particular i'm talking in
general what are the characteristics of
the cell type of persecutory general
the person
believes
that there's some threat in the outside
environment to him and if it was
analyzed by other people they mean
people would not come up with that
conclusion
so it's a false belief
that the person is in danger
that other people
don't agree with correct
the last part i didn't follow that other
people don't agree with wasn't the last
part of your last answer that if other
people
didn't see it well or other people would
try to talk the person out of it yes
so you'd agree with me that persecutory
type delusional disorder
could be characterized by a person
having a false belief
that there was a danger to themselves
that other people didn't agree with yes
that's broadly speaking about it now you
indicated earlier that you
received the version of events from
michael barrisson yes
and was that both in combination with
your interviews with him as well as
reviewing the written statements that he
gave to dr simran yes
you'd agree with me that by the time you
met with him
he had received discovery in this case
yes
and you'd agree with me that by the time
he wrote those statements for dr simran
he had received discovery
how does he know
yeah i'm not sure this witness would
know that well he could say that he
doesn't know that
do you know that doctor no no of course
not
did you ask him that
did i ask him whether he when he
received the discovery did you ask him
or were you aware if he had access to
discovery
when he wrote the written statement no i
don't know
now you wrote in your report that among
the defendant's fears
were that he told police
that lauren canara had weapons yes
did you listen to any of the 911 calls
in this case
yes
and you're aware that on july 31st
he would ask he was asked
if weapons were involved or mentioned
and his response was no correct judge
let me see a time mark
dr hassan i'm just going to re-ask the
question again because i'm not sure at
what
point i stopped but
you're aware then that on the july 31st
call to 9-1-1 the defendant was asked
were any weapons involved or mentioned
i'm aware he was asked and you're aware
that he responded no correct
you're aware that on august 1st he
called 9-1-1 yes and on that call he was
asked if weapons were involved or
mentioned and his response was no
correct
you're aware that on august 3rd he
called 9-1-1 yes and he was asked
whether weapons were involved or
mentioned
yes and his response was i have not
heard a word of that
okay
are you aware on august 5th that he
called 9-1-1 yes
and he was asked if weapons were
involved or mentioned
correct and his response was not so far
correct
you also i think testified yesterday and
it's in your report that
michael barisson told you that he
believed lauren canorack had declared
war on him correct
on the july 31st call to 911
didn't he indicate this is war and i've
had enough of these people i need them
gone yeah so i read that
did you ask him what he meant when he
said
that it was war with lauren canara
i took him at his face word
about his view
that um
lauren cataract had
issued some comments earlier that he had
read
using the word war
and then after listening to the 9-1-1
call from july 31st where he said
this is war i've had enough of these
people i need them gone you didn't ask
him what he meant by that no
and you agree with me that on july 31st
when he called 9-1-1 or around the time
he called 9-1-1
he didn't shoot anyone then
no
now i think doctor you talked in your
report
and indicated that the defendant was
taken to saint claire's hospital
well i saw on one of the forums that
said st claire's hospital
emergency at the squatter
so that was
that was a mistake in your report no i
was i did i say st class hospital it
said saint clear it was a staff member
for st from sinclair's
well i can direct you to uh page 11 of
your report which is s8
i believe you wrote on the august 7th
entry emergency medical staff at st
clare's hospital reported that on
arrival
correct the way i interpreted was that
these people said since it said on the
form
sinclair's hospital i assume they were
sent from sinclair's hospital
that's why i wrote that
now you also you referred to that
report
that emt report
yes
i think you testified some yesterday
about uh
when you were asked questions about
various types of amnesia and psychogenic
amnesia dissociative amnesia you were
asked the question
and you responded
with an answer about traumatic brain do
you remember that correct
now you're aware that there's no
diagnosis of traumatic brain injury in
this case
not from the experts there was a rule
out diagnosis of tbi
with altered
mental status
who gave that one of the doctors
i think the doctor who wrote down the
adjustment disorder had a rule out
diagnosis of
tbi
with the altered mental state
but you're aware that nobody actually
diagnosed any traumatic brain injury
correct
doctor you never asked michael barrasson
about when he first obtained ruth cox's
gun did you i did
is that in your report i don't know if
it is but i
from my recollection he told me that she
came in very late at night
and
he asked if she had a weapon and he
thought that
the cars could be subject to
either scrutiny or being
open and that he thought that she should
put the weapon in his safe
would it surprise you to know that none
of that is in your report
okay
you didn't think that that was a salient
detail to include in your report
um
i don't think it mattered what time when
or what time you put it in
so you don't think him obtaining the gun
that he's accused of using to shoot two
people
several days later that when he obtained
that you don't think that that matters i
don't think it's
for at least for me i don't feel it's
pertinent to my conclusion in the case
when he received the gun when he put it
in the sink
i have no further questions judge
what
redirect
doctor
yesterday the prosecutor was showing you
numerous articles
and different books with regards to uh
psychiatry
yes i do
is there an equal number of
articles
and books
that say the exact opposite thing
that he showed you without a doubt
two hundred percent
as a matter of fact after i left
yesterday
i read the book
that um
mr shellhorn referenced
so the record is clear you had never
been
shown that book or given advanced notice
that he was going to show that to you
correct without a doubt i didn't know
about that book i didn't know about that
reference
did you read that book last night i did
i got it through kindle
and it explains the mystery
and uh
what if anything would you like to say
with regards to that in reference to the
specific things that he showed you
well in chapter three
there was uh that's the chapter he
showed me judge not to interrupt but
could we just so the record is clear
i showed dr hassan a number of things
yesterday but just so the record is
clear he can indicate what he's reading
from
which book he's referring to this is the
book by um
john um
i want to say bachelor it's not
um
i forgot
yes james butcher james butcher
uh john batchelor was a radio uh
personality or was
um the particular item that he that uh
mr shalhon showed me
was a paragraph
describing uh paranoid
um
features if someone had a high score on
scale six
and i noticed when i looked at it there
was no uh numbers in there and just what
do you mean no numbers what do you no
scores
there's no scores i i was taken aback
and it was something short what's the
significance of scores well it's low
medium and high
they're completely different there was
none of that in there
so i got the book via kindle last night
and i read that section yeah i
understand why because the author of the
book
said i suggest
you um
look up articles
by other experts to get more in-depth
information this is what he wrote
chapter three provides a brief can i
just ask what page we're reading from
judge i have the book here so i can
follow along well i i have it from
location 897 in the book so i can't tell
you it's somewhere in chapter three
in the area where you showed me that
there were no t scores you had me look
at that with you
doctor
chapter three provides a brief overview
of each of the minnesota multiphasic
personality inventory hyphen two in
parentheses mmpi hyphen two clinical
content and supplementary skills in turn
more in-depth information on each of
these scales is available in any of the
standard mmpi hyphen 2 reference books
such as butcher richard williams
friedman
uh malinsky lewin
uh nichols graham and green
so over here yes this is a typical
reference book
by david nichols who was quite nice to
me one time when i called them up now if
you look in this book here it gives
specific information on scale six
and i referenced it in my uh my report
if you're very high on scale six
paranoia and your low on schizophrenia
it suggests that the person has a
encrusted delusional disorder targeted
to one particular person
and
a high score on scale six is indicative
or suggestive of a delusional disorder i
gave other references there but that's
what i found yesterday okay now
with regards to his questions concerning
famine
is it correct
if i can simplify the term as someone
telling the truth
not telling if you're fainting and not
telling the truth right that's what i
mean whether whether or not someone is
telling the truth correct correct
now
with regards to michael's
repeated statements
to
[Music]
first aid people
to
the ems
personnel
morristown medical
morristown hospital
and the
morris county correctional facility
where he said he didn't remember
did you take into account
those specific
medical reports and references with
regards to your determination as to
whether or not michael
barrasson was fading well feigning is
determined by testing
it's not determined by just your your
subtle opinion
if i found no evidence of feigning
either personality or cognitive or
neuropsychological with them with the
exception of the tom
that's
questionable results there anyway so to
answer you directly i found no evidence
of feigning there was repeated
references that he couldn't remember
the event
and
in addition to your testing
do those references
close in time to the incident
um
confirm whether or not
that
testing is accurate
i don't know about that i mean to me um
uh consistently he reported he couldn't
remember he was days there were
statements that uh he had partial
consciousness
and
that's
consistent with the possibility of a
mild tbi or
some type of uh extreme anxiety that
obliterated that memory
now
with regards to his statement testified
to
where he allegedly said i'm sorry in the
hospital were you aware that prior to
that he was injected with 100 milligrams
of fentanyl yes
and what if anything would
that drug fentanyl
i don't know that he's qualified to say
that he's not a medical doctor
are you familiar with the effects of uh
fentanyl doctor same objection
yeah if you're going to pursue this i
need to have a 104 hearing outside the
presence of the jury
all right questions with john
yesterday the prosecutor was asking you
questions
as to whether or not someone's
mistaken belief would affect
your delusional diagnosis
did you review the safe sport complaint
that lauren cataract made against
michael barrasso yes were there
allegations of judge woman
hold on there's an objection mr belinka
i didn't finish the question i i know
and there's an objection
it doesn't mean you keep talking when
there's an objection
say the same thing to witnesses
sustained
a prosecutor asks you questions about
the 911
yes with regards to questions that were
repeatedly asked
with regards to those specific instances
did the questions
concerning weapons have to do with
those this is going to call for
speculation
how does this witness possibly know that
if he heard the 911
you're asking him to interpret
the questions
and what was asked by the police officer
and what what the police officer was
asking can't answer that question
you have any follow-up
you may step down doctor thank you
any further witnesses mr malinkas no
judge other than uh admitting uh
numerous photographs which i don't
believe
right we don't have to do that now we
can do it at a break or at the close of
business we'll get on with the witnesses
so no further witnesses other than the
admission of some photographs and
defense defense arrests
mr
shellhorn does the state have any
rebuttal witnesses
yes
all right call your first rebuttal
witness judge this good can i have uh dr
hassan back in the courtroom yes you can
listen
judge the state we'll call dr lewis
lessinger
dr schlesinger
[Music]
so
my doctor good afternoon
all right left hand on him you know the
routine left hand on the bottom raise
your right hand please listen to my
court card do you suing the presence of
almighty god that the testimony comes to
this court regarding this matter shall
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth i do please state your
name as for your last name for the
record uh lewis l-o-u-i-s lesninger
s-c-h-l-e-s-i-n-g-e-r
thank you oh you may have a seat doctor
please keep your voice up nice and loud
if you don't understand the question
please indicate that i'll have counsel
rephrase
go ahead
prosecutor thank you good afternoon
doctor good morning
can you please introduce yourself to the
jury and tell them what you do for a
living um well lewis lessinger i'm a
forensic psychologist
what is forensic psychology it's simply
the application of behavioral science to
the law it's as simple as that
are you licensed as a psychologist yes
can you tell the jury about that i'm a
licensed psychologist how long have you
been places since 1976.
uh are you board certified yes can you
tell the jury about that
i'm board certified as a forensic
psychologist from the american board of
professional psychology i've been board
certified for well over 30 years
so there is board certification in the
field of psychology definitely
can you tell the jury a little bit about
your educational background
sure i received my doctorate my phd in
1975 from the new school for social
research in new york city i was a
trainee at greystone psychiatric
hospital from 71 to 73
i did my internship with the new jersey
clinical internship program in
psychology from 73 to 74 where i trained
at the new jersey uh state diagnostic
center that was the state's forensic
center at that time
i rotated i did another rotation at
trenton state prison and then trenton
psychiatric hospital the varun building
readjustment unit today it's ant klein
forensic center but used to be called
the varun building
i did some postgraduate training at the
new york center for psychoanalytic
training from 76 to 78 where i took
courses in
psychoanalytic theory and therapy and i
had a postdoctoral individual super
supervision from 75 to 77 which is which
is required
i'm licensed board certified
i am a tenured full professor at john
jay college of criminal justice in new
york which is part of the city
university of new york
and um i've been there since uh 1997.
can you can you tell us a little more
about that about your teaching
experience there doctor john jay college
is
the criminal justice um school for the
city university of new york city here
it's a mass
university baruch college is the
business school city college is the
arts and john jay is really new criminal
justice school
um i teach undergraduates master
students and doctoral students um
as well i
teach forensic psychology i'm a yeah
full professor of forensic psychology
and i was just going to ask you that
what type of courses do you teach well i
teach psychopathology um forensic
psychology crime scene analysis
and um homicide i teach a specific
course in homicide as well
can you tell the jury a little bit about
some of the professional activities that
you're involved in
well uh professional activities um
well i've had a lot of clinical
experience but other other than my
clinical experience i was um
elected president of the new jersey
psychological association in 1989 prior
to that i was a vice president on the
executive board
i was also
a member and later chair of the state
ethics committee from 1988 from 1982 to
1988 i was also a member of the forensic
psychology committee from 1980 to the
present
i was president of the new jersey
psychology political action committee
from 91 to 93
i was a member of the board of trustees
of the new jersey psychological
foundation from 96 to 98.
i was president of the society of
psychologists in private practice from
2001
to 2002.
i've been on the executive board of the
essex union county association of
psychologists from 2007 to 2008.
i was elected member of the council of
representatives of the american
psychological association
um i did that from 91 to 94. the
american psychological says
the council of representatives of the
american psychological association is
really like their executive committee
and
and so i did that for several years
i was also
treasurer of a division of group
psychotherapy and editor
of that group psychotherapy bulletin
i was an advisory board member from 83
to 88 of the american college of
forensic psychology
i was a member of the board of trustees
of the new jersey academy of psychology
from 1980 to 1987
i was a member and later chair of the
special classification review board at
the adult diagnostic and treatment
center at avenell i was appointed by the
governor of new jersey and the
commissioner of corrections that's the
board that evaluates inmates at the um
adtc sex offender unit and makes
recommendations to the parole board
for
for their release
i have been an associate editor of the
international journal of offender
therapy and comparative criminology from
2005
and on the editorial board of the
journal of threat assessment from 2000
from 1999 to 2003.
doctor can i just interrupt you on that
when you say that you're the editor of
something like that what does that mean
i was the associate editor not the
editor i was an associate what's that
well the editor is in charge of the
journal the editor has an editorial
board and they review papers that are
presented for publication that's
basically what you do they're not a
journal is not limited to
the editorial board very often they'll
send it out to external reviewers as
well
since 2000 i've been co-principal
investigator on a major research project
with the fbi behavioral analysis unit
down in quantico
um
where we studied we have thousands of
extraordinary crimes there's files we
got from the fbi
and we have a major research project
where we study extraordinary crime
sexual murder serial murder serial rape
suicide by cop bias homicide
um domestic homicide and other forms of
um serious climate which resulted in
some major publications
as well
in 2004 myself and four of my colleagues
at john jay conducted
the research on uh sexual abuse in a
catholic church
by uh priests and deacons from 1950 to
2002. um
the u.s conf was under the auspices of
the uf's conference of catholic bishops
the u.s conference of catholic bishops
reached out to john jay to do this
for a couple of reasons but
one is
the um
because we had the fbi project
it was going so well let me say one
thing the fbi is a very paranoid
organization they don't not like to
share their information with others so
but they did with us in terms of all
their files you have a room almost the
size of this just filled with files
there was no problem at all in terms of
confidentiality or anything like that so
um the head of the fbi at that time the
the
deputy had a left
and was hired by the us conference of
catholic bishops to conduct this study
and because of the very good experience
that we had with the fbi that's how john
jay was selected to do it so we did that
and we presented our results um to to
the bishops
i have also been a member of the senate
task force on internet uh information
for registered sex offenders um
i was i was appointed by the acting
governor and the senate and the senate
president um what happened was um new
jersey needed to uh redo megan's law
that's a community notification
um of registered sex offenders
and
before they did that they put together a
task force
i was on it representing
mental health
there was someone from the prosecutor's
office the defense bar
senator um and verso was on it it was
megan megan kanke's senator
joe vitale who was
a senator as well as on it
was someone someone else someone from
rutgers was on it as well i think
and we um
basically rewrote the law we held public
hearings and so on
and there was a number of reasons why
that had to be done but it's not
relevant to anything
else
i've been uh
on the research advisory board of the
fbi then specifically the national
center for the analysis
of violent crime at the behavioral
analysis unit from 2010 to 2012 and i've
been a periodic instructor at the fbi
since 2008 although i haven't been there
in a while
we're all shut down
and so on
and i've had a lot of different jobs
um
over the years clinically i was just
going to ask you if you could tell the
jury about some of your clinical
clinical experience right so um in
addition to being a a tenured professor
i've also had a private practice of
clinical and forensic psychology
since
1976
i was a consultant at fair oaks hospital
or now at some called summit hospital
from 76 to 2000
where i worked with adults and
adolescents and almost exclusively
psychological evaluations very limited
therapy only early on
i've been a consultant at little hill
alina lodge in blairstown new jersey
from 1998 to the president that's a
substance abuse union a long-term
treatment program for substance abuse
i was also on the staff of the va
medical center in east orange from 1976
to 1999
and there i worked on their alcohol and
substance abuse program i worked on
their uh compensation and pension
program that's where veterans get
evaluated for ptsd
and that type of thing but i also
founded
a violence clinic in the va which the
clinton the purpose of the clinic was to
evaluate people with respect to a
problem with violence
and then we treated them and it was the
first uh violence clinic in the entire
va system
and it became um brought into the ptsd
program when the ptsd program started
and so and i coordinated that from 77 to
92.
prior to that i was on the staff of jfk
medical center in edison i worked
in their mental health center and i also
worked at the rehab unit
as well
and i was a consultant to the edison
police department the juvenile aid
bureau from 75
to 70
75 to 76.
have you ever received any awards uh in
recognition of things you've done uh yes
can you tell the juries about some of
those awards yes um
in 1990 i was
awarded i was awarded psychologist of
the year by the new jersey psychological
association
in 1993 i received the karl f heiser
presidential award from the american
psychological association
in 2003 i received the distinguished
service award from the society of psych
from the society of psychologists and
private practice
from 2005 to present uh to the present
i've been a distinguished practitioner
in the national academies of practice
the national academies of practice is
based up of nine medical specialists
including psychologists and each
specialty is limited to a hundred people
in that specialty and the purpose is to
advise the united states congress on
matters of health care
and so i i've been on that and in 2014 i
received the distinguished researcher
award from the new jersey
psychological association
i was just going to ask you about some
of your uh professional organizations
that you're a member of yeah uh i'm a
fellow of the american psychological
association a fellow is a little bit
different than being a member um i was a
member for many years but when the
american psychological association
determines that your work your
contribution had national impact they
can elect you to be a fellow it can't be
local or state they have to determine
that it was national impact
so i'm a fellow of the apa
i've been a fellow of um the new jersey
psychological association i said i was
president of that um a while back
i'm also a member of the american
academy of forensic psychology i'm
actually a fellow of the american
academy of forensic psychology it's not
on my cv but i am
a member of the essex union county of
association of psychologists the society
for personality assessment and also a
member of the international rorschach
exchange
and um
what's that
it's just a scientific group that sends
out um
once or twice a year uh a
book called russia canna and it's this
research and and
people write things about their their uh
research on the roadshow
have you ever published anything related
to the field of psychology yes can you
uh tell the jury have you ever published
any books i've had 12 books published
in 1978
i published violence perspectives on
murder and aggression
in 1980 i published handbook on stress
and anxiety
in 1981
psychopathology of homicide
in
1983
the title of the book was sexual
dynamics of anti-social behavior and
there was a second edition in 1997.
in 1989 i published sex murder and sex
aggression
in
1996 i published explorations in
criminal psychopathology clinical
syndromes with forensic implications and
there was a second edition of 2007. the
the reason i published that was
clinical syndromes with forensic
implications because the dsm often
doesn't do
well with a lot of disorders that are
forensically related because the dsm
really wasn't set up to be a forensic
manual it's set up for hospital practice
mental health centers offices and so on
so um so that book
supplemented it in in a sense so what
you mean is there is there nuance to
applying diagnoses from the dsm in a
forensic setting
well not nuanced there's disorders
that are um
that you see are we still doing
qualifications at this point
uh i think we are are we mr show we are
all right save that question for later i
will just
so moving on you were telling us about
some of your books yeah and then 2000 i
published serial offenders current
thought recent findings
um in 2004 sexual murder cataphramic and
compulsive homicides a specific type of
sexual murder and uh the second edition
came out last year in 2017
i uh published a book titled psychiatric
aspects of criminal behaviors the
collected papers of eugene ravich this
is an edited book eugene revitch was a
psychiatrist and a teacher of mine
and um
he actually became a mentor of mine and
we became colleagues and friends
and um his
papers many of which were published in
the 1950s and 60s and 70s are as
relevant today
as they were then and they meant so much
to me when i trained i almost memorized
them and i didn't want them to get lost
in the archives somewhere so i put it
together into an edited book where the
first part is on sexual aggression the
second part on criminal behavior and the
third part of the book is on epilepsy
and epileptoid violence dr revich is
also a neurologist and there's a number
of articles in there on what's called
paroxysmal manifestations of
non-epileptic origin sounds fancy but
all it means is an explosion that's
really not a result of epilepsy
sometimes that's hard to differentiate
so um
so that's that book it was a book of
honor really to somebody and got really
really good reviews um
i i which i was happy about
but i had nothing to do with the content
i just put it together
doctor have you ever written any uh
chapters in any books yes i've written i
think about 25 uh chapters in um
in different people's books i've been
invited to write chapters and um
about so i think it's around 25 chapters
in different books some were my own
books some were many were other people's
books as well have you ever published
articles in any journals
yes i've published
about i believe it's 43 articles in
peer-reviewed scientific journals
what's what's a peer-reviewed scientific
journal a peer-reviewed scientific
journal is when you publish an article
researcher it doesn't have to
necessarily be research it could be a
theoretical article or a literature
review
you send it into a journal and then you
get what's called a blind review your
identity is removed uh all identifiers
are removed and they send it out to
three four five experts in the field to
review it your peers and then they give
feedback and then you
do what you have to do um and so that's
what that's what the peer review process
is it's a
it's a fairly long process and in many
top journals there's about a 90
rejection rate so a lot of people don't
realize that but i've published in all
of the top uh journals
including uh the american academy uh the
journal of the american academy of
forensic psychiatry
behavioral science in the law
journal of forensic sciences
journal of family violence
international journal defender therapy
and comparative criminology
um
and other and other in other top
journals and a lot of it is on uh
various it's almost all on criminal
behavior and extraordinary criminal
behavior sexual murder
serial sexual murder necrophilia crime
scene staging undoing which is symbolic
reverse electro homicide crime scene
foreign object insertions
uh and so on we recently published and a
lot of this was in collaboration with
the fbi because we have their um
extraordinary cases from all over the
country
um and recently i we published an
article on confessions um you know you
hear a lot about false confession
there's a lot of research on false
confession but our study was not on
false confession was on confessions how
do people confess because people confess
in different ways depending upon
their crime
doctor have you ever testified uh at a
trial
yes
what uh can you estimate approximately
how many times you've testified that
trial uh i never kept a record of how
many times i've done this and i'm not
good at estimating how many times i've
done things but i've been doing this now
46 years 100 200
perhaps 300 times i i just don't know
and were you qualified as an expert yes
what are some of the topics that you've
testified regarding i mean i've
testified in state of mind cases
insanity diminished capacity passion
provocation duress voluntary
intoxication competency to proceed
competency wave miranda rights
sentencing issues
um
have you ever been hired
obviously you're here testifying as my
witness said on behalf of the prosecutor
today have you ever been hired by the
defense i have in the in the first third
of my career i've testified just about
exclusively for the defense i was hired
mostly by the defense in the last third
of my career i've been retained mostly
by the prosecutor and in the middle it
kind of went in different ways
have you ever given an opinion that was
different from the party or the side
that hired you yes
can you estimate in the last
call it 10 years approximately how many
times that's happened well i can tell
you the ex the exact time
in the past 10 or a little bit longer 10
maybe almost 15 years because i have a
record of it and the reason i have a
record of it is
someone asked me just that question
maybe 10 12 years ago
and and they asked me essentially did
you ever get hired by the prosecutor for
example and gave an opinion uh
consistent with the defense expert and i
said yes now when you're in court and
someone asked you if you ever did
something and you say yes the next
question is how many times did you do it
and i didn't know how many times i did
it so i kept the record then uh
of the times of the various um offices
that i was retained by uh as well as
defense as well as the fence and so what
is the number in the approximately last
10 to 15 years that you've given an
opinion different from the party that
hired you okay now you want a number so
i'm going to have to count this so
just give me a second okay just give me
a second
um
okay i i i came up with 30.
30 right yeah 30. since you started
keeping track yeah
doctor do you have any experience with
psychological testing
um
yes i have um
i have extensive experience with
psychological testing
psychological testing is very simple
it's a beta it's simply a way to measure
mental process it's it's it's really
nothing more difficult and more
complicated than that
and it's generally pretty
straightforward psychological testing
but i will say if you don't know what
you're doing you can really mess this up
real quickly
i'm sorry no i was going to say i taught
psychological testing for over 20 years
when i was on the faculty of um the new
jersey medical school i was in a faculty
over there i don't know if i even
mentioned that but i was in a faculty
over there at um umd and j for um from
90 from 77 to
99 i think in 2000. for 23 years i
taught psychological testing to third
year medical students who rotated
through psychiatry service
i also conducted a year-long
psychodiagnostic seminar
for our doctoral interns who were
training over at the va
and
did that for over 20 years
as well
in addition i've published two papers on
the rorschach
um
in journals
i also developed my own projective test
entitled
the criminal fantasy test and it was
really based on as a projective test and
based on the format of the thematic app
reception test which is simply a test
you show a person a somewhat ambiguous
picture and their job is to create a
story based on the picture and you get
kind of their inner fantasies their
inner thoughts and so on because
sometimes an individual patient or
otherwise if you ask them a question
they won't tell you directly but if you
give them a test and ask them to create
a story very often it's revealed in that
so i i was always impressed with the
content that i got from the tad so i
worked with an artist a colleague of
mine worked with an artist and we
developed a criminal fantasy test of 12
different ambiguous sorts of crimes and
the object was to create a story about
it it was published in 1981 in the
journal of clinical psychology
at that time a number of test publishers
wanted me to develop this into a market
a marketable test where you could you
know sell it and that sort of thing and
i did not do it i should have done it
it's one of my greatest professional
regrets because i think of all of the
people that i saw over the past 40 years
but i i didn't do it but anyway
i did that
also
i discussed psychological testing in
several of my books or many of my books
and how to do it what to do what not to
do and how to go about it and so on
would you ever render a diagnosis based
on a psychological test no you never
render a diagnosis based on a
psychological test psychological testing
can support a diagnosis a diagnosis is
made clinically and it's made based on
the clinical criteria symptoms and
behaviors delineated in the dsm-5 now
the dsm-5 this is a diagnostic and
statistical manual of mental disorders
it's been around since 1952 it goes
through different editions that's how
you make a diagnosis based on symptoms
and behavior now what's the value of
testing well testing can support a
diagnosis or it can go in a different
direction and not support a diagnosis
but you never make a diagnosis based on
psychological testing as a matter of
fact if you look at some of the tests
that have computer printouts i don't use
those but a lot of people do it says
very clearly these are hypotheses these
are suggestions these are for your
consideration but no they answer your
question directly you never make a
diagnosis based on psychological testing
judge at this point i'd like to offer dr
schlesinger as an expert in the field of
forensic psychology
mr blankes do you have any questions as
to the qualifications of the doctor or
any opposition
all right
all right based on the background of dr
schlesinger uh as outlined in his
testimony i do find pursuant to rule 702
of the new jersey rules of evidence that
he qualifies as an expert
and he may in forensic psychology and
may testify in the form of opinion
i make this determination based on
his
education his knowledge skills
experience
and training
and extensive work history
all right very good he'll qualify as an
expert go ahead mr michelle horn
doctor is there any difference between a
psychologist and a psychiatrist in a
forensic setting uh yes yes there is
there is a difference
there's a difference in training a
psychiatrist after college goes to
medical school and studies medicine
and then he or she does a four-year
residency in psychiatry where they study
you know diagnosis dsm and usually
treatment with medication not all the
time but usually treatment with
medication and some
uh psychotherapy
um
a psychologist after uh college goes to
graduate school for four five six years
depending upon
their program and their how they get
through it
and gets training in behavioral science
and psychopathology diagnosis evaluation
uh
and testing
and treatment and so on and then a
psychologist does um a clinical
internship a pre-doctoral internship and
then he does
at least a year of post-doctoral
supervision or more
psychologists and psychiatrists trained
together i mean i've been trained by
psychiatrists dr revich was a mentor of
mine and he was my
he's a psychiatrist he was my main
teacher
and um
and so i've been trained by
psychiatrists but i taught the medical
school for years um i taught
undergraduates that's medical students
they're called undergraduates
in medicine um
uh for years
um i taught um interviewing with with
them the testing i said with the third
year residents and i was with third-year
medical students and with a psychiatry
residents i uh supervise them
uh with um their you their experience at
the substance abuse unit and
specifically with group therapy and
evaluation of respect for substance
abuse in addition psychologists and
psychiatrists practice together all the
time i practiced for 25 years with a
psychiatrist in summit sergio estrada um
you know we each had our patients he did
medication i did psychotherapy i did
evaluations for him um it's a great
collaboration so and you know i i've
worked with them and
throughout and very very very clearly
that's the difference basically
doctor in this case were you asked to
see and examine michael barrasso uh yes
do you see mr barrison in court
um i think it's this i think that's
michael sitting next to his attorney
although i will say it looks very
different than when i saw him can you
describe uh what's different about it
when i saw him he was well groomed and
looked appropriate and now he looks long
disheveled hair
that's not how he looked when i saw him
do you recall approximately when you saw
him
um i saw him
uh
exactly on january 29th march 12th and
april 29
2021 last year
and doctor are you referring to a copy
of your report yes
judge i'm just going to indicate for the
record that that was marked as s-404
for purposes of the record all right
very good
doctor when you were first asked uh to
see and examine michael barissone uh
what did you do first
well first i did psychological well
before i saw him i familiarized myself
with the discovery and and that's that's
what you have to do a forensic
assessment
has three parts
the facts of the case that you get from
the discovery the discovery is the
police reports and witness statements
and all the rest
the second part of a forensic assessment
is the psychopathology is there a
disorder what's the disorder and so on
and the third part is that the jury will
take the facts and the disorder second
thought and relate it to a legal
standard whatever that is
now in this case uh you indicated that
you did review discovery and that that's
an important part of the process uh do
you recall what discovery you reviewed i
reviewed the complete states case
everything there was thousands and
thousands of pages of text messages and
everything and there were um
uh um
videos you know recorded statements
i was just gonna ask you did you watch
or listen to any of the recorded witness
statements yes some were videos
statements some are just uh audio but i
i listen to everyone yes why would you
listen to the statements or watch the
statements as opposed to relying on a
summary or a report
well you can read the summary of the
report too a lot of the statements are
summarized in the police report but
that's not the way to do it you want to
see exact that's some person saying what
they've found to be significant and you
you are obligated to look at it yourself
and make your own determination and get
a you know get a look of what the person
said in whole not just a summary of what
the person said
did you also review any uh
reports that were authored by uh any
psychiatrist hired by the defendant yes
and that was that dr simran dr simran
do you know dr zimmerman i know dr
simmering very well i've known dr simran
for over 30 years i have the highest
regard for dr simmering he's a friend of
mine dr simmering is competent he's
experienced he's intelligent he's funny
and he's and he's extremely nice guy
which i think i said to you at least 50
times
and i've worked with stock dr simmering
on cases i've worked opposite dr
simmering on cases i referred cases to
dr simmering he's referred cases to me i
have the highest regard for dr simran
but i disagree with him in this case but
it has nothing to do with my high regard
for dr simran have you agreed with him
in certain cases yes and have you
disagreed with them in certain cases yes
do you know how much time you spent with
michael barrasson in this case uh yes i
spent
13.25 hours 13 and a quarter hours and i
think i meant to ask you and i'm not
sure if i did
were you aware of dr simran's diagnosis
in this case yes and that's why you said
you disagree with them in this case
correct
now you indicated that you met with
michael barasona that he looked
different when you met him yeah what was
his demeanor when you met with him
well when i first met with him he was
very very tearful i mean he was crying
uncontrollably he almost at times was
hard to console him
um he was very upset about the whole
thing and if i could just refer to my
report
yeah he was tearful emotional crying he
became animated at times particularly
when discussing uh lauren
and
robert goodwin and the whole
circumstances uh with respect to that he
would stand up get animated and so on he
was very emotional um about it and um
yeah he did that
but he he you know he after i caught he
calmed down and he participated fine he
was cooperative completely answered my
questions
except for some resistance towards the
end
now how would you describe his ability
to recount uh certain things that
happened
michael's memory from as to what
happened was excellent
he's i spent hours with him i think it's
over six hours maybe talking about what
had happened he gave me a day by day
account of the activities that happened
sometimes it was an hour by our account
now occasionally he would say well july
24th we uh you know i woke up and i did
this oh by the way there's some
something happened on july 23rd and then
he would go back to that but that's
normal that's how that's how people
remember things and recall things but he
remembered in great detail
everything i was very impressed by his
memory
how would you describe his concentration
during the times that you met with him
when i was with him his concentration
was basically okay i was with him for
hours and hours at a time now he was
emotional he was crying and so on but he
was okay his concentration was basically
okay
what would you say was the most
outstanding clinical feature that you
observed
i was just crying and is being so upset
about the uh about the whole thing he's
extremely emotional and um and animated
that was the most outstanding uh feature
other than that um no he was pleasant he
was pleasant to deal with pleasant to
talk to he was
very appropriate
and um
nothing bizarre or unusual in his
demeanor other than what i just said or
what he said
now you described in general
what a forensic evaluation or
examination entails
how do you look at criminal behavior
criminal behavior is best understood
in three stages
the pre-crime context criminal behavior
doesn't come out of nowhere there's
there's a context to understand it then
there's the actual offense itself and
then there's the post-crime behavior and
that's really the best way to understand
from my perspective a psychological
perspective criminal behavior and how do
you
learn that well you learn that from the
discovery you don't learn that from what
the defendant tells you you learn that
from the discovery i should say
one i should correct myself
a very nuanced thing that i just want to
say a little bit different
yes he told me what happened on a
day-by-day hour-by-hour sometime basis
but i i want to emphasize that's his
perception of what happened i'm not i
don't know if everything he told me is
exactly correct
um but that's what his perception was of
it
but
yes
and i think you you described earlier
doctor you started to talk about the way
memory works
and can you explain a little bit more
about that in light of your last answer
well memory is not there's no video
camera inside here that makes a
videotape of what goes on memory is a
constructive process we construct our
memory if somebody asks you what did you
have for breakfast yesterday you'll
probably give them an answer but it's
constructed it's not that you
necessarily have an exact memory of it
it's so you know yeah pretty we'll find
what you think and then you'll
underconstruct america that's the way
human memory uh works and you have you
know you can have an event i mean you
see this in in legal practice all the
time not necessarily criminals say an
accident three people look at an
accident and three people give
statements are those three statements
going to be exact no they're not going
to be exact that's how they perceive it
people perceive things differently based
on many factors and if people perceive
things differently does that mean that
one or more of them is having a delusion
absolutely not
doctor you indicated that you uh
as part of your examination
uh gave the defendant some psychological
tests yes
and i think you you outlined those
beginning on page 50 in your report
okay just give me a second please
yes but before we get there can i ask
you
how do you choose what tests you're
going to use in a forensic examination
yeah
i give
psychological testing
to ev i won't say every single person
but i would say 99.99
of the people i give a standard battery
of psychological testing too
i give the rorschach the thematic app
reception test the bender gestalt
projective figure drawings the mmpi 2
and a version of the wechsler scales
that's an intelligence test
if the case requires i'll add additional
tests
um
tests for malingering mental disorders
for example tests for malingering memory
memory for example and other types of
tests as well but i give that standard
battery to everybody why i just want to
get a measure i want to get a baseline
measure of the individual and when i
start my evaluation in the forensic case
i start with psychological testing i
don't start with what did you do
what happened no i start with that
because it's a sort of a breaks the ice
you know and does some simple tests and
it's a rapport builder and this type of
thing so that's what i do
now in this case did you give the
defendant any tests related to
intellectual uh examination yes what did
you give him i gave the
wechsler-abbreviated scale of
intelligence the wechsler-abbreviated
scale of intelligence is an abbreviated
intelligence test that has a .93
correlation with the complete wechsler
adult intelligence scale revised means
you're tapping essentially the same
thing now why did i give him the
abbreviated test rather than the full
wexler intelligence scale very simple
intelligence is not an issue in the case
meaning intelligence is not an issue
before the court
if intelligence was an issue before the
court for example
the issue is competency to stand trial
based on limited intelligence
not necessarily intellectual disability
borderline intelligence so on then
you're obliged to give the full test if
it was competency to waive your miranda
rights based on intelligence if it's a
social security disability evaluation
for example and intelligence is an issue
then uh yes but there but in this
particular case michael is an entirely
intelligent individual
he ran a very complicated business he
had um with lots of moving parts um he
had a location in new jersey had a
location in florida there was a lot of
people that were employees there were
students and trainees there there were
animals there horses there's all kinds
of consultants coming in horseshoe
people and veterinarians and whatnot um
he said these monthly expenses like
thirty six thousand dollars a month
that's a lot of money that's a a very
big and complicated business he's highly
intelligent intelligence is not an issue
in this case prior to seeing him i also
read dr simran's report who described
him as highly intelligence uh and i gave
some weight to that as well um so
there's no need in my judgment to do
anything beyond what i did
now after giving him that test did that
uh
corroborate what your impression was
going in yes let me uh refer to my
report on page 50. i found his um full
scale iq
intelligence question 119 that's the
highest end of average just one point
below superior his verbal comprehension
index is 120 that's superior and his
perceptual reasoning index is 112. this
is all above average intelligence
there's nothing wrong with michael's
intelligence nothing he's an intelligent
individual
did you give him any tests related to
personality functioning uh yes
can you and
i know you had already said you give a
standard battery of tests
what in general are the the
uh to be personality functioning tests
looking for we're looking at well you're
generally looking at personality from
different perspectives from different
ways i gave him the rorschach i gave him
the thematic appreception test the mmpi
2
and projective figure drawings and
there's a combination here of projective
tests
and combination and the mmpi which is a
more objective let's say quantitative
test
as well and i know you said you give
some of these tests to establish a
baseline but what specifically do you
hope to learn by giving these tests that
would have value to your entire
examination sure well the rorschach for
example has been around since the 1920s
this is an excellent test if used
properly
it's a very good test to determine
reality contact reality testing for
example you show a card and some of
these cards look like bat and
butterflies and that's everybody i think
knows that from the media and whatnot so
a a person says who looks like a bat a
butterfly or some sort of winged
creature that's pretty good reality
testing what if a person says to you
that looks like an enemy
well that's not that's not typical and
that gives you some insight into that
it's very good to determine if there's a
thinking disorder a formal thought
disorder does the person say for example
it looks like a bat because here's the
wings here's the body here's the antenna
here's the feet that's very logical
thinking what if a person says to you it
looks like a bat because of that white
dot right in the middle
what bats have white dots that's showing
a disorder of thought they're drawing a
giant conclusion based on a tiny bit of
information that's a red sign
what if a person says it looks like a
bat
response one looks like two alligators
over here on the end response two
that's fine what if a person says it
looks like a bat with alligators
attached to its wings now that's a
thinking disorder that's a problem with
thinking you're putting parts of reality
together that should be kept separate
and so some of those are some of the
things you get from the rorschach
also
the rorschach is also very good to give
you personality structure how strong or
weak is the underlying personality
structure for example when you go to buy
a house you hire a structural engineer
not just to look at what the painting is
outside but to you know go take those
tiles you know off with a flashlight to
see what the structure is to see how
strong the house is the rorschach is a
very good test to determine whether the
structure is the level of a personality
disorder um more severe structural
disorganization schizophrenia or
something like that
so it's a it's a very good test to fuse
properly
now before i ask you about the rorschach
in this specific
case
i wanted to ask you uh a little bit
about the workshop itself are there more
than one
testing uh or uh scoring system yes
there's there's um
there's been a number of scoring systems
used over the years rorschach himself
it's rorschach because that's his name
herman rorschach he had his own system
another guy named samuel beck had a
system uh bruno klopfer had a system um
zigman piotrowski had a system there's a
whole bunch of these systems i trained
on the bec system but i switched to
klopfer because it's much better
clinically i think it's actually the
best
what happened in the uh mid 1970s to um
to the 1980s a guy named john exner
came around and created
his own system he called it the
comprehensive system why he said well
all these systems are good i'm going to
put it all together and i'm going to
make it in a very quantitative fashion
which sounded good and everybody was
interested in that
now i had training on the exner system
from john ecksner
how because back in i can't remember who
was 79 80 or 81 when i was the va john
extra came there he was promoting his
system all around the country and he's a
good marketer he really really is good
and he gave a series of lectures maybe i
don't think it was more than five five
two hour lectures to go over his system
um
but i never liked it now now why didn't
i like it not because i'm so smart
because i'm not but what he was doing is
he was making the rorschach which is a
projective test something that it's not
it was never really intended to be that
but okay he wanted to do it in a
quantitative way
the system really became very very
popular throughout the world
particularly in the 1980s and the 1990s
and and schools were teaching this
and workshops are given all over the
world and computer printouts and books
and all the rest of it
the problem began in the mid-1990s
where
it was determined that there was a lot
of problems with the test in terms of
its validity
now i should say this also
exner put together what he called
the exner
research council that members of the
research council are were top
still are they're all alive a top-notch
people who did research and promoted
this and did workshops and so on greg
meyer is one joanie maher is another one
don viglione is another one phil erdberg
is the fourth there's one other person i
can't remember
and when and these are top-notch people
and when they started hearing this that
there's problems with the system
they thought initially maybe this is one
off
and then more more problems came
and then um
by around 2000
it just became untenable
and uh john exner died i think was 2006
about 15 years ago and i i asked i mean
one of the people on on
the exeter research council is a good
friend of mine phil erdberg so i asked
him did you wait the external to die
before you before you completely they
laughed i never got an answer but i
think i know the answer anyway um
they decided they did research on their
own and they said this can't go on
and they published um a meta-analysis a
m-e-t-a a meta-analysis is an analysis
of analyses
and they published it in a prestigious
journal called psychological bulletin
and a couple of other journals as well
that really talked about the problems in
the journal that it's just and the
problems were too there's problems with
the normative data and the validity data
the normative data means how the test
was normed by exner he didn't do he
didn't collect information and send it
out for the peer review process he
didn't do that he collected information
and put it in his book and said these
are the norms so that's a problem
and the validity uh data as well um now
i gave you a number of articles on that
now i didn't follow all of the details
of the problems with the exner system
because i don't use it
i knew that there was a problem with it
because phil herbert is a friend of mine
we discussed and and and so on and
and and to be very direct a lot of
people that promoted this were quite
embarrassed
when this started happening because
don't forget they were spending years of
their professional career teaching this
promoting it and so on and so what the
exeter research council did after they
published a series of articles
concluding
that it's not a valid
system of scoring and you shouldn't use
it now i want to make something clear
this is not my opinion this is not an
opinion this is a conclusion reached by
the exner research council those
individuals closely connected with exner
and the and the system
they decided to put together and they
were committed to a quantitative
approach to rorschach and they put
together a new system they tried to redo
it they thought first maybe we could
redo it cut this they said it was just
not salvageable and so they put together
a new system called the rorschach
performance assessment system and i
think i gave you a manual um and all the
people listed there are all the people
on the exner rorschach council um do you
have another question
yes you're fine we're getting a little
too narrative here
yes i had asked them about the the
different scoring systems and about the
extra system we heard a lot about that
yesterday no i i understand
just
ask another question to follow up if you
need to doctor at some point were you uh
made aware
that another doctor named dr charles uh
hassan had examined the defendant in
this case uh yes and were you provided
with a copy of his report yes are you
aware whether or not he uh
administered the rorschach test to
michael barrisson uh yes he did
uh no he did oh wait what just give me a
second i see you're what's a little bit
distracted i'll wait until yeah
um
no he did not administer uh the
rorschach to him he used my rorschach
findings and said he rescored it using
the exner system and he submitted it to
the exner um computer program which is
still there i should say yeah you can
still get this obviously it's run now by
exner's daughter uh she's not a
psychologist and she works with a
psychologist in france europe and frank
i think it's france and um and japan and
so you can still get this so yes i'm
aware of that he administered to him he
rescored it using the exner system
now you said that you use the clopper
system correct
what were your results after uh scoring
michael barissone's
war shock with the clock protest
well again it's not just the see that's
another problem that's not just the
scoring system uh you know i heard so
much
you know about scoring systems that you
know the rorschach is not just read it
to a scoring system it's how i explained
it before so my findings from the
rorschach i found that there was inner
anxiety conflict and tension problems
relaxing
um
there were a number of what's called
achromatic perceptions there was uh
attention to the um it looks like uh a
bat because it's black using the the the
black color which is a marker for um
depression or depressive vulnerability
um
so he has symptoms depression anxiety
he's not withdrawn from the outside
world
his inner life is dominated somewhat by
impulsive tendencies and there's some
form of acting out
likely there his responses that he gave
were well connected to the stimulus
material his reality testing was
completely intact there's no evidence of
a thought a formal thought disorder his
thinking was clear and logical there's
nothing suggestive of schizophrenia
psychosis or even borderline traits he
gave two slightly regressive perceptions
and that's um
throwing paint fireworks that type of
thing and it's very very consistent with
you finding individuals who have a
personality disorder and uh
those were the responses in my report i
concluded exactly on page 52 what his
responses were they're logical
well-formed well connected to the
stimulus material upon which they were
based meaning the reality testing
is good
and
no structural disorganization um
i also found there's a capacity for
empathy he had an adequate number of
human perceptions which means he has an
ability to establish good interpersonal
relationships uh with people
um
did you render any diagnoses based on
the results of the rorschach examination
no you never render a diagnosis on the
basis of any test a test
can give you just what i said all of
these different indices and that could
support or not support a diagnosis but a
diagnosis again is never based on
psychological testing
doctor moving on to the mnpi
uh
what what if you could explain that test
in a general sense
it's 310.
i don't know if anyone else needs a
break
i do
if you get my meaning
so um we're just gonna it's gonna be
short because i know we're just sitting
in the afternoon so just ten quick
minutes
relax for ten minutes use the facilities
if you have to do that and we'll come
back at twenty after and okay all right
very good
[Music]
[Music]
you can step down doctor
you can just step